i i've been following your work forever
and i don't know i don't know i always
wanted to know how much gets back to the
director but on sunday night when the
super bowl aired the spot for the
question to make commitments started
trending because people were like is
that patrick's stupidity
i know you can't answer it but i just
wanted to know like does that get back
to you do you know you're trending do
you know people are like hey he's in
obviously you're like he's on twitter
all the time
at all
i i don't look at a lot of social media
good on you and that is mostly a time
issue
but um i must say
before bedtime on sunday evening
i had had plenty of communications
friends and some people i hardly knew at
all of making reference to
is that you
is that you he's a werewolf
i was just at home the baldest werewolf
i've ever seen so yeah how could it
possibly have been me
i was watching american football my
favorite past
i mean do we really imagine patrick
stewart is waiting to watch the super
bowl wait and watch football he also
said it was before bedtime so i imagine
patrick stewart is a little sleepy cap
and his platter with a candle on it and
his slippers sticking his head off the
window and saying you boy what day is
to bedtime and to sleep with watching
the nfl game and the rams unfairly win
it
oh sideways as my head is rescued
logan is that you
oh
then but uh patrick stewart we love you
and uh thanks to chris from cosmic
culture for getting that scoop seriously
asking the right questions i love it
when these interviewers ask the right
questions oh welcome back to new rock
rockstars the professor can deny it all
he wants but somewhere on the multiverse
of madness set is a chess set in a
wheelchair with ex-folks because
professor x and the x-men are now here
in the mcu but we've gotten so caught up
on hearing his voice what the illuminati
is and what other mutants might be
coming that we haven't really figured
out how they're here now sure yes
multiverse disney owning fox yeah we get
that but are we talking some no way home
logic are we talking some other
narrative backstory that explains how
the mutants are here now
where they're going to be going forward
and how much of the x-men series we have
to watch to consider to be true required
viewing mcu canon what the x
i'm trying that out this week
uh this is inside marvel it's new
rockstars marvel reaction show i just
had a bit of a jet bridges marble marvel
marvel rock or a box of crap
subscribe subscribe
patrick stewart was wearing my dude i
can't get over it it's like literally
like knives out quality sweaters i don't
know where they get it i mean he's warm
major easter eggs on that sweater i'm
telling you look at the look at the
stitching there are x's there are cross
hatches there's little dark hole cover
shapes i think i see
in there
i think i see shot at us right there on
the shoulder
i got to break down that sweater
sweat down the sweat now sweat down is
what i do when i put on my socks uh so
that was what i do when i watch two
steps
well the marvel world is still reeling
from the confirmation in the latest
trailer for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness that the fox x-men
are joining the mcu patrick stewart ryan
reynolds both having denied being in
this movie but uh you know andrew
garfield playing werewolf taught us that
we can just politely ignore their
hamstrung disney publicity scripted
answers to these questions they got to
do what they got to do they got to do it
and they're playing a game we know what
the game is it's fine we're we're
enjoying the ride the real question
though is the logic marvel studios is
cooking up to explain how the x-men are
now in the mcu right is it gonna be like
no way home where it was just seemed
like a possible temporary crossover
probably not right it's gonna be a more
permanent one and as we're wondering
with daredevil coming from no way home
are all of those past titles in their
catalog mcu canon now how much of their
backstories those characters backstories
firmly part of their backstories now are
they variants uh is it just gonna be
politely ignored or only brought up when
it's convenient for their new storylines
we'll talk about that today so we want
you before we talk about this to check
out the new batman inspired t-shirt
designs over at newrockstarsmerch.com
they aren't marvel this isn't sorry
but i i did that marble mouth just to
you know allow you to insert anything in
there in this case i was really saying
inside blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah
but the batman shirts guys cool as hell
and the batman's coming next week it's
gonna be a very big week in the nerd
world so you're gonna want to celebrate
it grab one quick you can have it for
when you go to the theater and see that
movie like a true gothamite so check out
those shirts and all of our cool
clothing and merch offerings over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
but mt let's dive into our big question
this week okay buddy our first question
of the day is how using what logic will
the x-men have arrived into the mcu in
multiverse of madness era yes it's a
great question mt and i i think in the
past whenever we've talked about x-men
being in the mcu or not being allowed in
the mcu it's always been about the
legality of it like right originally
mutants couldn't be in the mcu with the
avengers because marvel had sold off the
film rights for the x-men and the
fantastic four to fox back in the 90s
right leading to these two separate
cinematic franchises and then uh in 2018
disney bought all of it back from fox
they bought pretty much all of fox's ip
that's why you can watch this i feel
like that was like yesterday but like it
was 2018 that's like a while ago now wow
well that's when the process these kind
of mergers take years to really figure
out so that's when it was announced and
then now it's pretty much complete uh
and we've just been wondering which of
these marvel titles are finally going to
announce the x-men and now we finally
have it uh but i think deeper than that
legality question last week i made a
video about like which has their x-men
old cameo and it's that was more of a
question of which other x-men do we need
to see again just as fans
like kind of a a recap of the history of
the x-men film franchise that i highly
recommend you go watch because i think
that's kind of how marvel is looking at
it trying to put their uh their heads in
the eyes of the fans who look back on
things like days of future past and
x-men first class and
logan all those other titles um but now
that patrick stewart is pretty much
confirmed to be in multiverse of madness
it's actually happening we still don't
fully know the story logic that explains
how he got here and why it has to be
patrick stewart as charles xavier by the
rules of this universe slash multiverse
like spider-man no way home of course
set the stage for this to make sense to
general audiences the rule being mcu is
one universe that exists alongside
parallel universes that just include
past previously separate film franchises
so if the raimi verse and the webverse
peter parkers are just part of that
multiverse presumably so are the fox
x-men they're just gonna wreck connie in
it as being in a separate reality that
can now be brought over into the mcu but
the issue is what brought the variant
peter parkers was a specific spell by
doctor strange called the ruins of cough
call specifically that spell going awry
and i think it was important that that
had to happen in the sanctum crypt
because they had that line when they
were headed down to the basement saying
that the sanctum walls were built at the
intersection of cosmic energy currents
that plus wong warning that this spell
uh traverses the boundaries between
known and unknown realities etc etc seem
to be like this spell in particular just
kind of it walks the line a little bit
right it it's one that requires it it
pulls its energy from the grid in a way
that isn't healthy for anybody um so
really when that all got patched up at
the end of no way home it seemed like
they were suggesting that it could be a
one-time crisis
they kind of made that movie in a way
that of course we would we want to see
toby and andrew again yeah but they did
it in this kind of open-ended way to
where next time we see toby or andrew
would just be back in their home
realities right and then maybe in some
future crossover event they didn't have
it so that all these characters are just
now in the mcu going forward they went
back to their home realities but i think
something much different is going on
with the mutants obviously i think
marvel studios wants mutants permanently
in the mcu so it's not a curtain call
for these characters it's really a
reintroduction uh it's a new beginning
so professor x appears in this location
that we assume to be the citadel of the
illuminati which presumably is
structured similar to the tva from loki
it's a courtroom it's a bunch of offices
it's a prison that exists outside of any
one reality it's kind of in a neutral
zone
a nexus point between the realities so
if we look at it that way there's a few
ways to explain how this charles xavier
exists here one way is that this is just
the professor x from the fox x-men films
and perhaps the charles from the days of
future past rebooted timeline which is
set after the events of the first x-men
because gene grey is still alive uh hank
mccoy as kelsey grammer is there um but
i would assume this is not the charles
xavier from logan who dies in that movie
yeah because he would have a lot more
holes in him it would be a bit harder
for him to you know yeah it would just
require a bit more of an explanation um
but this could also be a charles xavier
from another branch reality that we have
never seen before yet still played by
patrick stewart just with different life
experiences now i would imagine many of
the same biographical beats like growing
up in a westchester mansion his
friendship with eric lyncher but not the
movie by movie uh story moments from the
brian singer simon kinberg matthew
vaughn series so this could be uh like
charles xavier perfect example maybe a
live-action version from the 90s
animated professor x which could tie
into your next in 97. which is oh my god
god bro i would honestly to me that's
the most exciting
way you could argue that's the perfect
amalgamation of the charles xavier fans
want to see played by patrick stewart
his performance but the backstory of the
of the animated world which fans as
goofy as that show sometimes got is
still just like perfect yeah that would
be like that that that show is so
revered by marvel fans like because like
that was one of the first marvel shows
that i ever saw so like if they were to
include that
into the illuminati like or into the
doctor strange events like at all that
would be a huge win but for marvel and
like a super smart move so i i love that
yeah
i think there's a perfect opportunity
there but i think ultimately the idea is
this illuminati is composed of the
brightest leaders the brightest minds
who came from universes that on their
own achieved breakthroughs in
multiversal tech right so the way
nathaniel richards the kang variant that
he remains did in his um his backstory
in loki episode six uh these are just
brilliant engineers maybe on their own i
guess you could argue maybe there was
one other engineer who came over and
introduced it to them just kind of came
through a portal and says hey hey use
this because we know rick and morty
inspired all of this this could be
someone who who said hey your portal gun
sucks but this is how you really want to
do it um but they reached the uh they
reached their status in the illumina in
uh but it seems like these guys reach
their status in this illuminati citadel
by leaving behind their home realities
they're representatives of realities
we're not seeing them back in their home
states they're in congress multiversal
congress right now
uh so they're products of something
larger so really the question is beyond
this illuminati will this movie follow
charles and these others back to their
live-action x-men universes alongside
other fox x-men actors are we gonna see
hugh jackman are we gonna see ian
mckellen halle berry james marsden and
that is really what people i think want
to know now like how many of these x-men
movies all of them soon to be added to
disney plus i'm sure do we need to watch
and treat as mcu cannon as required
viewing
for that matter how much of daredevil
which also will probably make its way to
disney plus sometime soon i think the
logic that sam raimi and mike waldron
and kevin feige are going to suggest is
that
something similar to no way home like
obviously retconning the fox x-men
universe is part of the mcu multiverse
of separate realities but also to do it
in a way that doesn't erase or tread on
the stories that came before because the
no way home john watson whole team had a
ton of respect for the rainy verse the
webverse they didn't do anything to
change or retcon those realities those
film continuities were left intact yes
maybe new realities were formed
thereafter but it's not like when we
watched the raimi trilogy any of those
events were erased now right and kevin
feige this is especially the case for
the original x-men movie piece kevin
feige we mentioned plenty of time worked
as a associate producer for that first
x-men film in 2000. he's got to have
some respect for that past series so
therefore i think we can expect
multiverse of madness to show brief
glimpses of the fox x-men reality but
nothing that erases the continuity or
changes the continuity of what came
before like imagine a glimpse of
professor x teaching a class that is
westminster at his west chester mansion
maybe wolverine the alkali lake lab but
might instead build some new alternate
realities with these actors like a
father-daughter moment between ian
mckellen magneto and elizabeth olsen
wanda maximoff just kind of using the
pieces of what came before to build
something new and that way kevin feige
and his team is not beholden to what
other directors other screenwriters
other casting directors did before uh
and it just seems like the mutant
arrivals will be some mix of you know
dark cold magic gone too far by dr
strange wanda maximoff in this movie
reality obviously has been destroyed in
all kinds of ways from what doctor
strange did in
no way home and back in avengers end
game in infinity war wanda maximoff now
through what she's done one division
which she's going to be doing a lot more
of but i think at the end of this movie
obviously we're going to get a house of
m no more mutants esque moment that
permanently leaves mutants in the mcu
obviously it seems like where that's
going but like with daredevil kevin
feige's gotta approach this a la carte
i think that's his mindset he doesn't
want to have to feel forced to
committing to rehiring every past box
actor every past netflix actor including
the ones that fans aren't that excited
about so for now i think we can apply
what i'm going to call the daredevil
rule
i don't even know if it's a rule yet but
how we're looking at daredevil from no
way home to whatever fox x-men will stay
in the mcu after the events of
multiverse of madness like one two maybe
three of them doesn't mean all of them
but it could could mean any of them some
characters will probably be recast but
for daredevil and for kingpin professor
x
these guys were probably not exactly the
guys who lived every moment we saw on
daredevil or in the fox x-men movies
right however their power sets their
relationships the major biographical
beats that make them who they are i
think will stay the same i just don't
expect charles xavier to reference jean
grey disintegrating him in the last
stand but maybe he'll vaguely reference
playing chess with his old frenemy eric
lyncher
so uh i think that's how we should look
at it right now they're gonna bring back
some characters some characters will
stay in the mcu some characters will
only stay in this movie and i think if
you're gonna bring in patrick stewart
you're probably gonna have some of those
other big faces from those past films
and they're rather than like doing what
end game did and restaging past uh films
i think they're just going to build
something new out of it to show other
realities we haven't seen before
um but i i've been talking way too long
mt i got to hear your thoughts how do
you think this movie is going to explain
charles xavier patrick stewart's arrival
to the mcu i know first of all dude i
love hearing you talk i love all your
insights like here you talk like helps
me generate ideas so i'm just like oh
please boy please um but no um i think
that
you're you're very much on the money
there in terms of um marvel and kevin
feige not wanting to erase um the past
stuff that happened in the fox x-men
because it means a lot to fans and to
kevin feige because he's very much
started off the x-men universe working
alongside um
you know um all those people like wolver
uh hugh jackman like you call him
wolverine hugh jackman and patrick
stewart he is don't call him jackman
he is wolverine um but i definitely
think that we're going to get like some
type of merging of these universes
together by the end of multiverse of
madness that's just like
that sort of basically says yeah
everything that happened to us in those
fox movies it did happen but now we're
just going to just like put all the best
elements that people liked from you know
x-men 1 x-mean 2 level by x-men 3
probably um and you know just shove them
all into this world and just like
to remove everything that people didn't
like and remove all the you know the
actors that we can't recast and like
sort of just like reinvent it sort of
like the way that they did after the
seeker wars event with the um the
merging of earth 616 and 1610 together
like they just basically just they took
miles morales they took all the like old
man logan he's like oh we're taking all
the best parts from different universes
and just shoving it into this to our
main universe um so that we can just
play with them with the with the main
cast so i think that um probably uh
these whatever doctor strange did to
cause these um the manipulations of
reality of the messing up realities it's
going to trigger like the secret wars
event that everyone is very much hoping
that marvel studios gets to
and uh which is you know essentially
um it begins with this conflict of
universes just coming together and one
universe having to destroy the other to
survive and i think that this because we
have this illuminati that is comprised
of all the smartest minds in the marvel
multiverse
there has to be a purpose for that
because like you know and it we do have
rumors of a superior iron man tony stark
and we do see the robots in the trailer
like these mines are coming together to
stop a very big
threat that not even a tony stark who
invented time travel could do on his own
he's like i need help
mine's greater than my own so we're
going to see probably just
representatives from um each of these
major universes um maybe maybe a sony i
don't know how that deal is going to go
but like it's definitely going to be the
smartest minds of the fox and in marvel
studios heroes um just coming together
to try to keep this the realities from
coming together and like meshing close
together but it's inevitably going to
happen because we have to see our
favorite heroes from fox's past just
interact with our avengers i want to see
avengers versus x-men marvel let's let's
get it going yeah i think it's all
headed there for now um i'm just trying
to imagine what this looks like and to
me empty the coolest version of this is
part of the reason why i'm so excited
patrick stewart is back cerebro
some of the coolest visuals yes from the
early fox x-men films was patrick
stewart explaining to logan explain to
the other x-men how the cerebral
technology worked and the visuals of
that were beautiful imagine this
professor x built a multiversal version
of cerebro that allows them to access
other variants through the multiverse
and we see just these little vignettes
of them in a cloudy mist wherever they
are in their reality and that way you
could just kind of insert any characters
any alternate versions of these actors
in another alternate moment whether it's
you know
uh wanda maximoff and her brother pietro
on wounded gore mountain uh or maybe
it's uh the two of them with daddy
professor x in a mutant-dominated
reality called the house of m uh maybe
you just see other mutants other
alternate mutants fighting other
alternate mutants you know like there's
like all all these cool things that you
can do with the cerebro and i think
that's this version of uh of charleston
xavier that we're seeing and and the way
that like just casting jonathan majors
to just exposition dump on us for an
hour of television
[Laughter]
how fun is it how fun is it just to have
patrick stewart explaining things to you
like i get to sit back and listen to his
voice explaining how the multiverse
works and it's gonna feel so simple
we're just gonna nod along and be like
yeah okay yeah that makes sense why why
did i overthink it that much
way more sense just to have him do it so
i think that's what it is he built a
multiverse cerebral uh
upgrade uh and that's how he got on this
illuminati we're looking at a version of
charles xavier i think from that days of
future past reset
timeline i think i think it's just going
to be implied that logan is from another
reality of that and i i guess the
question will be how will this charles
xavier describe himself is he going to
say
after my x-men were able to fix the
timeline from the 1970s and prevent the
trask industries from creating sentinels
we got lucky and i focused my attention
on ways to keep order in the multiverse
so no one had to suffer or is he going
to say i used to be a cartoon
and now i'm
in a different medium
[Laughter]
i'm so round logan
do i look this thick from the side
is my ass still thick luke
i got dumps like a tree
i still have my dump truck ass
i mean it seems like he's in some kind
of chair my hope is that he's in a
hovered chair yeah i know i've been
preaching that like that there's only
six chairs um some of you on twitter are
like well there is a spot for a seventh
chair in the middle there but there is
no chair there but i think the argument
is that's going to be where charles
xavier rolls in or floats in so there
might be actually seven members of the
illuminati gonna be bonkers that's gonna
be interesting to think about i mean
seven is more of the uh it's a round
number right if you if you have if you
need an odd number of people to vote on
something you need to have yes that's
true that's about six
it's a more godly number so like since
the illuminati like to sort of act like
gods it's like all right seven we're the
seven but but six doesn't make sense
considering the mcu and six right right
that's that was why i assumed just
because the illuminati were six but also
the illuminati was like dues functional
in the comics it was nice very much so
very much a failure i would say i mean
we got we got uh a world war
hulk out of that thanks to them those
anyway well we have another
huge character from the fox x-men
franchise we've got to figure out how
it's going to fit into this and that's
deadpool another character another actor
who says no i'm not going to be in this
we'll talk about deadpool in a second uh
but first we want to thank some friends
who helped us make this episode starting
with our friends at masterclass with
masterclass you can learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace you can learn how to
cook from wolfgang puck improve your
writing skills with rl stein or learn
gymnastics from simone biles and with
over 100 classes from a range of
world-class instructors that thing that
you've always wanted to do is closer
than you think here at new rockstars we
are huge fans of the writing and
filmmaking classes there are classes
from directors joda apatow spike lee
acting classes from the mcu zone samuel
l jackson natalie portman the class from
former disney ceo bob iger was super
interesting because he goes into a bunch
of detail about disney acquiring marvel
and the creation of disney plus
obviously stuff that informs our
theories here at new rockstars so the
classes are really well produced and you
can watch them on your computer your
smart tv any device where you stream the
classes are made in these great 10
minute chunks so you can watch one part
when you have a few spare minutes or
bench through the whole thing i highly
recommend you check it out get unlimited
access to every master class and for the
inside marvel audience you get 15 off an
annual membership so go to
masterclass.com marvel now that's
masterclass.com marvel for 15 off
masterclass we also thank peloton for
sponsoring this episode keeping things
fresh is the best way to stay motivated
and keep from burning out on doing the
same thing over and over and over again
well peloton is pushing you further with
a whole bunch of fresh new ways to work
out on a peloton bike and peloton bike
plus they have new classes new music and
new ways to keep your workouts fun and
motivating i'm actually excited to take
the guided meditation class that they
have on the app i've tried meditation in
the past and enjoyed it but i haven't
stuck with it so i think having a
peloton instructor there to guide me
through it will help me stay motivated
on the opposite end of the exercise
spectrum they also have a new boxing
class that's uh you know great even if
you've never boxed before i never boxed
never fought before uh letting out some
sweaty aggression sounds like a nice
compliment to my meditation goals so you
know all the balance is all things
should be so peloton has a workout for
every day every schedule de-stress from
a long day with 30 minutes of strength
and 20 minutes of cardio or do quick
15-minute total body class before work
stay motivated while having fun with the
bike workouts and yoga and dance cardio
and more so visit onepeleton.com to
learn more that's
t o o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n dot com and we
want to thank upstart for sponsoring
this episode up start if you have
multiple credit card balances each month
and are only paying the minimums barely
making a dent in your credit card debt
it can be discouraging but upstart can
help you pay off your existing debt
quickly so that you can feel like you're
finally getting ahead whether it's
paying off credit cards or consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
that you are more than just your credit
score so rather than looking at your
credit score alone upstarts model
considers other factors like your income
your employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate without
impacting your credit score in just five
minutes for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan so find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you so uh
getting back to multiverse of madness of
course last week ryan reynolds also
denied appearing in this movie and again
none of us believed him but assuming
this movie either features uh deadpool
in it as a cameo or just explains the
logic by which he could come into the
mcu for his later confirmed third
deadpool film and see i wouldn't ask you
how do you think multiverse of madness
will set up deadpool three and uh when
deadpool 3 comes do you think we're
gonna get uh an addressing of the thanos
cable issue oh we definitely have to
like
because like you know the way deadpool 2
ended with with deadpool using cable's
time traveling device to sort of right
the wrongs and deadpool and ryan
reynolds life um that that's not going
to be something that the either the tva
or the illuminati are going to be super
thrilled with
so i definitely feel like you know a
deadpool uh three was definitely going
to be ushered in via the illuminati
because like we see the illuminati
arresting doctor strange for you know
violating
the natural law and you know mordo seems
to be affiliated with them and so like i
don't see any i don't see a more bigger
violation of a multiversal natural law
than what deadpool did at the end of
deadpool 2. very a huge violation like
so many timelines messed up like it's
just not okay so this man and probably
probably cable as well because cable
violated the rules as well because he
went back in time to try to um
assassinate that little boy and so
those two guys are in big trouble and
they're probably both going to get
arrested and i think that we might see
like a more of a continuation of this
buddy cop um type of like you know uh
what's the word a dynamic between uh
this buddy cop dynamic between
josh brolin and ryan reynolds deadpool
yeah in deadpool 3 where they have to
like sort of just fix their mistakes uh
with the illuminati uh but what do you
think how do you think it's going to set
up difficult three it's it's interesting
i definitely want deadpool to appear in
multiverse of madness even but i just
want like a short little cameo that
doesn't really answer a ton of questions
yet because ultimately at the end of the
day deadpool as on his own is so meta
and the way deadpool 2 ended is is just
so goofy and insane that i don't know if
deadpool 3 needs multiverse of madness
to answer those questions like deadpool
3 already had him
basically spiraling through timelines
through different other movies
through you could argue the the fox
x-men universe when he showed up at the
end of
wolverine x-men origins of wolverine
right where he shot his previous self
like so he's already crossed over into
that reality and i think just by having
him in a background cameo like one or
two jokes right like that's enough for
me i don't need him to team up oh yeah
doctor straight in america chavez and
this movie i think that might be too
much he would overtake the movie so i
think just one quick jokey thing
um
like during that cerebro montage or
something like that
doctor strange is smashing through
different realities we smash through one
where deadpool's there he just looks
over and goes
god
stay the hell out of my world you know
like some kind of quick joke
uh and then and then in deadpool 3 we
get our own answers and everything it's
just so meta like the fact that deadpool
2 referenced the the matthew vaughn
reboot era of the x-men characters even
though that was supposed to be in the
past
but then i guess those movies never had
the characters age even characters who
weren't supposed to be ageless they like
uh nicholas holtz never looks older in
any of those movies not enough jeffy
turner never looks older in any of those
movies doesn't make sense anyway i'm
going off the rails but i uh i think
when deadpool 3 comes out um it can just
leave it to the people writing that
script and the people coming up with
that movie to provide the answers of how
deadpool ended up in the mcu um because
i think tonally he's just kind of his
own engine he's his own world uh and
no you can plug him into any cinematic
franchise and it'll make sense because
he'll just joke his way through it what
i really want for cable honestly is like
i want that to be a running joke he's
now in a reality where everyone's like
ooh
like were you related to him and he's
like why does everyone say i look like
him well we'll leave it there for this
episode of inside marvel mt thank you as
always always great to just pick your
brain um so don't forget to check out
our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com if you're over 818
go on and click that link for the new
rockstars discord server in the
description and join that conversation
you can follow me at eavos follow mt and
mastertainment subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching
you